hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et utam le styliste dû cliquer
sur démarrer pour que notre aventure
commence je t'attends rejoint moins vite
sur messenger l'orangé
[Musique]
dans mon élément
le suc est celle de l'état
[Musique]
je
fois j'étais pieds c'est donc j'ai pas
de quelques vaches à lait et sur les
bancs du rapport
[Musique]
avant il faisait tourner les filles mais
toutes les filles habillées en engageant
la fin du show
[Musique]
clic
sur comme l'équipe la plus
non
[Musique]
bach
digne
[Musique]
hanouna
il est plutôt
et sa vie toujours tonga
hors cac40 trois ans à l'ana et la vie
on a tous déjà vu ça
fut parce que celle de faire ton cul
hanouna oulala
[Musique]